the afghan army is now
all that stands between every town and
the taliban
the soldiers who've relied so much on
international training
air support and weaponry are now being
left to tackle the taliban insurgency on
their own
every time that they leave their
barracks they know that they are the
focus
of any attacks by the taliban because
the taliban want to show
that they're coming back into power and
it's only a matter of time before they
take over
the taliban's already moved into dozens
of districts across the country
and they're circling the capital
roadblocks are set up to try to secure
the perimeter
but the weapons on the streets indicate
just how insecure afghanis are about
their own safety
the uncertainty is palpable and there's
a great deal of tension
everywhere
the afghan soldiers fear they're now
fighting al-qaeda
and isis thought to already be embedded
within the taliban
and the scramble by international troops
to get out of afghanistan
appears to have empowered their enemies
who've had some rapid successes on the
ground
there's an awful lot of land that they
have got to try and get back
from the taliban and without those
international troops
they have got their work cut out for
them but the civilians are growing more
nervous
with reports of soldiers surrendering
and bases routed
but every soldier we spoke to is putting
up a brave front
the taliban tried to disrupt by laying
mines he told us
but we use our technical teams to find
them before they explode
but that confidence and the ability to
take on the taliban
isn't matched elsewhere
the rocky terrain of northern
afghanistan is home to the country's
most formidable fighting partnership
different fighters known as mujahideen
who joined forces
to form the northern alliance the relics
remain in the pangshi valley of how they
beat back superpowers like the soviet
union
and kept the taliban at bay
the son of the man who led them to those
victories is now stepping up to stop
this new taliban takeover
we were given rare access as his convoy
of
suvs and armoured vehicles crisscrossed
the region
often at high speed
there's a feeling there's no time to
lose with the taliban trouncing
areas in the north but the security
force with him
is devoted to him and his cause
if talib will not accept the peace
we will fight with them okay you're
ready for this
yeah absolutely
hundred percent masood was only 12 when
his father was assassinated two days
before 9 11.
the young man educated in london has
enormous support here
when he talks they listen and the crowds
in his home region are looking to
him to lead them in the new fight
against extremism
the young masood insists the national
army needs help
and without international troop support
the mujahideen are the only fighters who
can give it
he says there are thousands like these
men armed and ready to beat back the
taliban and their extremist allies
they're going to fight for democracies
we speak today they're going to fight
for the rights of the people
they're going to fight for the rights of
the woman
and they're gonna fight for many other
values that we cherished and we love
and we achieved in the past two three
decades so these are the things that
they're ready to defend
the preparations for battle come amid
predictions that the afghan government's
heading for a swift collapse
prompting a fresh migration crisis and
increased
isis attacks we are the first line of
defense we are defending europe we are
defending the region
and afghans are fighting not just for
themselves but for everyone
but former president karzai urged
afghans to all lay down their guns
and saved his strongest criticism for
america
the west must explain to us the presence
of the ash in afghanistan
it emerged during
the u.s prisons in afghanistan in the
name of fight
against extremism and terrorism
so they have failed america may dream
this is the end of its longest war
but those arming themselves now ready
for more battles
fear it is far from done